foreign
so I guess we're just using previously
in this show previously to what to this
episode to the moment I'm watching it to
a time when Marvel gave a about
their shows and actually put any effort
into them also a full 70 seconds of
recapping the first five episodes of
this show that should have been a much
better for 60 Minutes of a movie I've
decided scroll blood is way too purple
instead of this looking gruesome it just
looks like someone's kid found the
finger paints I've dialed this number a
million times
this is just the first time I pressed
send except you don't press send to ring
to English call and you might think
that's pedantic and ridiculous but I'd
remind you this is TV since there is
nothing too shallow for us to add to
Cindy's counter we'll send anything the
only thing we can't send legally is
Traverse City Michigan and that's only
because we signed a treaty in exchange
for their cherries everything else is
fair game we're gonna find out in a
second not Nick Fury exited this car
after lining up this straight shot for
the vehicle to act as a decoy my
question is how did he escape the car
without these two guards spotting him
they're clearly looking right at the
vehicle from 50 feet away did he use
that ridiculous tunnel laser from Winter
Soldier again making your main AI prompt
for these credits how about a bunch of
green blobs and make sure it goes on for
at least two full minutes because
there's nothing a modern audience loves
more than sitting through two minutes of
green stuff president vladimov has
strenuously denied responsibility
meaning your fictional Russian president
vladimov if you want to make him Putin
do it but this middle of the road
is annoying oh he's strenuously
denied it then I guess we're all right
then I mean it's no more ridiculous than
how over the top and pushy you're being
about attacking Russia this is the pop
calling the kettle strenuous did you
take a stupid pill with your breakfast
this morning Admiral I guess now that
the show knows that we know that Roadies
a scroll all guard rails are off on his
villainy the problem is the show didn't
know that we knew what they thought we
didn't know long before they wanted us
to know it you know and it's the
Russians 100 while I'm glad we've moved
away from the Ludacris one thousand
percent nonsense the scourge of the
hundred percent is still very real
please be advised there are very few
situations where humans should have 100
certainty about something your help in
ending this disease is welcome
oh you know your finale is boring
when one of the villains can't even stay
awake this wasn't even scripted I heard
Don Cheadle actually fell asleep during
filming and because they were short on
time they just left it in poor dude now
I'm scared for armor Wars Fury
why are we concerned about Fury we got
enough security for him this is a valid
point and the idea that cocky fody would
in any way Panic about old man Fury a
person whose strength he is scoffed at
this entire series is ludicrous 100 to
The Last Stand of the great Nick Fury
shows over optimistic tagline somehow
makes it into the final episode Fury
tell me you got a backup plan
your Avengers on standby are you kidding
with a 212 million dollar budget for six
measly episodes I hope this finale has
at least a few Avengers on standby what
else would the money even go toward what
about that invisible cloak and shield
um actually graphic the show was called
Cloak and Dagger but I don't blame you
for getting the title wrong nobody
remembers that series you're too busy
playing dress up
using my skin like a costume show again
hints at what could have been an
incredible exploration of appropriation
in the black experience and again fails
to even give a moment to the deeper
questions the audience might be asking
if I find any Nuance or depth when you
can stop at keeping things Skin Deep he
turned to war people into a band of
Beggars and what I'm supposed to emulate
that
I'm supposed to be like Taylors and put
my trust in you you
Theory possibly the greatest sin of this
series is wasting this incredible
Kingsley been a deer performance It's
haunting captivating and powerful and is
languishing in a show that is anything
but it's also Olivia Coleman you wasted
her too you marvelous morons also also
Graphics sure does seem to have a lot of
rage build up for Fury I mean he really
hates the guy good thing the show rushed
through its story in typical Marvel
Disney plus fashion so the audience
didn't get any time to see gravic coming
to hate Fury or having tiny pieces of
his heart torn out with every kill yep
six episodes was plenty you're right I I
failed you I
I failed you this whole speech might
have had a chance of being very
meaningful if it was actually Fury
saying it but because the show needs its
big twist we never get any kind of deep
exploration of how Fury really feels
about his role in all of this somewhere
in a nuclear facility Marvel has a
genuinely interesting and nuanced take
on this topic hooked up to a machine so
that this show can be a pale imitation
of it because it's easier
save the lives of 8 billion people
than it is to change their hearts and
Minds I see once again we're playing the
earthlings can't handle an alien species
inhabiting their Planet bit so how once
again remind you that new Asgard exists
you know
the last thing I felt
before I flaked dog no I don't and
neither do you what the is up with
the lights flashing as these agents are
shot is the shooter standing right next
to the light switch panel with a gun in
their hand what exactly does making the
hallway dark for an entire second
accomplish was the shooter running low
on darts and hoping to induce a seizure
that's not what I think it is do you
think it's all the Avengers DNA in a
convenience suppository form because
that's what I thought it was I think the
radiation's eating your brains mate
right because how could he think he has
any leverage and why would he even bring
it with him if he wanted to make a safe
trade and how could he even guarantee
that you would follow through on getting
off the planet it's almost like you
should have known this was a setup by
this point if confidential strike orders
have to travel and be transferred hand
to hand to be executed then I all of a
sudden have a severe distrust in our
government's ability to execute anything
quickly it's like military protocol was
designed to create false plot tension or
something
oh both
hook that vile up to anything you just
stuck it in your little microwave with
tubes inside this cannot be how a DNA
reader works also how is your little
computer able to identify all of this
DNA if you didn't already have known
samples to compare them to how is the
computer programmed to recognize the DNA
of thanos's henchman ebony ma even if
you somehow collected his blood there's
no way you'd be able to identify it the
Harvest is just a dumb idea altogether
with more holes in it than the beer can
I shoot my BB gun at every weekend so
here's let's just say 30 sins
okay you move them in here clearing a
room but missing the British lady behind
the door in the bright pink Overcoat
they line the doors you
growl how does not check behind doors
make him a scroll is that a well-known
and publicized Marvel fact that Scrolls
never checked behind doors
surprise twist not shown surprise
and I've got a Drax arm because that
makes total sense
also why did Gaia get his sleeve tattoos
those were part of his DNA they were
added to commemorate important moments
in his life so why does the mother of
dragons have them this climax makes no
sense also title of my sex tape this
hole he's the real villain shoot him
cliche goes on for all the sometime the
show has already established they could
just shoot Roadie in the arm and he
changed back proving he's a scroll it's
remarkable how you can just rush through
an entire series and have so little to
put in your finale I'm almost impressed
almost I think Marvel expects us to all
be furiously fancerbating over all these
combined Powers but I'm over here
thinking you can go Hulk or Captain
Marvel and you thought an ebony Ma Pa
was ever the right move this 10 second
shot of a missile silo opening for a
missile we all know will never be
launched help nudge this final episode
over 30 minutes great work much
excitement sir you're looking at your
enemy actually Nick the president is
clearly looking at you in this next shot
unless you're implying you really are
his enemy these two finally decide to go
Captain Marvel at the same time because
as if this same versus same finale
wasn't enough on its own Marvel's now
made it several little same versus same
as within one larger scale same versus
same it's like a never-ending Marvel
trotska of Russian nesting trolls
[Laughter]
she went from zero to full mantis so
fast does just having the DNA cocktail
give you the expertise to even use the
powers you might have like you can give
me the DNA of Jordan and I might get
taller but I'm not dunking from the free
throw line 30 seconds later now that I
think about it this show basically
steals its plot from Space Jam and that
explains a lot sure I'm glad we gave
Amelia Clark Captain Marvel's Powers
rather than just you know bringing in
Captain Marvel the scroll expert really
Dodge to Bullet there I have all these
powers and I choose uppercut flag chop
neck grab and there you go Gaia is now
the most OP Marvel character to ever op
sure the shows and movies will now
wrestle with that in ways that
completely make sense show wants me to
believe the president of the United
States can cancel a nuclear strike while
calling from an unknown British cell
phone show should be prepared for
disappointment just like I was going
into this finale how long have you been
in here asking a question that the
person you're asking it to would have no
way to answer and that the show you're
on has no interest in revealing yet also
it appears Rhodes is wearing a hospital
gown which probably means he's been a
scroll since after his civil war
injuries and if you think I'm not giving
a handful of preemptive sins for the
Roadie that was at Stark's funeral being
a scroll you have failed to grasp how
seriously I take my responsibilities
here this dumb way too curvy
intersection that is why tonight I'm
presenting to Congress for immediate
emergency authorization a bill that
designates all off-world-born species
enemy combatants man those poor guys in
new Asgard are the Scrolls lost
one home but they asked Guardians are
apparently about to lose home number two
We Know Who You Are
[Music]
you are we will kill every last one of
you presidents I
love
you
scroll lip yes well let's be sure not to
repeat the mistakes of Talos and fury
wait who tell us
did you just pronounce both of those
syllables wrong isn't it Talos just
because you're British doesn't mean you
get to waltz in here with your
hoity-toity queen speech and change how
names are pronounced although I guess I
should be thanking you because now that
the show itself can't even agree on how
a name is pronounced that'll keep people
in the comments from saying I'm saying
things wrong
what a world that would be and leave
love and friendship out of this cutting
off my Gaia false worth fanfic efforts
before they'd even begun I will use you
you will use me immediately encouraging
my guy a falsworth fanfic efforts after
you just thwarted them sci-fi property
ends with a person discovering a
warehouse full of Clone Android hosts
cliche give me a break
there's only one way this ends is it
with Mulder and Scully showing up
because that's the only way you're
getting any sins back on this episode if
you truly care about the Scrolls
get off my Planet but it's not your
planet for instance just the president
of the US right or is it more like a
Nixon Futurama situation good news from
saber Cree said they're open to peace
talks with the Scrolls first since we
don't know what saber stands for yet we
can't officially know how to say it and
if Furious pronouncing it correctly so
here's this info withholding that
information and second the creaser
opened to peace talks man with that
information it almost makes this entire
series completely disposable I mean if
the show hadn't done a good enough job
at that on its own also how did that
work with the blip was the war suspended
as half the Korean the universe
disappeared and when they came back did
the war start again I have so many
questions and I'd love to do more
research on this but I'm already in my
pajamas that I love you
as I
only
as you are although now that I think
about it maybe back to the uh human
teeth during makeout sessions and other
mouth-related activities
that's not a real arm it's plastic and
it's the Russians 100 100 100 100
but I killed him because of you
I learned it by watching you first I'm
gonna kill you
I say we hang him then we kill him
this this thing that you do when you
whip your hair when you're fighting with
the arm and the hair and you do like a
fighting pose and said yeah it's a
fighting pose you're a total poser We
Know Who You Are
I will find you
and I will kill you